having fun yeah Oh James has been having
fun how come no one else has been having
did you go to James's talk wasn't that
fun no ah i was there James I was there
I came three times you're talking and
I'd left three times during your talk I
was great that's great ah who learned
something new so far almost everyone
great come back tomorrow you'll
definitely learn something new let me
see such and is coming up first he's
ready but we still on where the doors
closed does everyone is everyone here
ever everyone's here we're okay we're
set to go such I think we need a mic
adjustment you want to hold it yeah hold
on so everyone can hear me at the back
all right such and we'll be presenting
first again these are lightning talks
you have five minutes at the end of five
minutes James is going to start
applauding and everyone just join in if
they're still talking clap louder and
eventually we'll pull them off and you
know cut the microphone you only get
five minutes and then it's done that's
it we'll move on to the next person next
person is rob p review our if you can be
ready to jump up rather excellent but
first we have such and who's going to
talk about deep and easy learning yeah
so what my name is such an and so I've
done a PhD in mission nanny but I guess
these days I've been moving bit more
into the deep learning side of things
right so just a give me an idea of what
it is i'll talk about it does the most
simplest case first of all this there's
only one layer and forget about this F
right so what we want to do is wait wait
it so that we get a the output Y and we
keep adjusting the weights when we have
a hidden layer what we keep doing is
same ideas here except we stack them and
we want to adjust them until they output
seems about right right so we try to
minimize minimize something some sort of
given metric so in this talk I'll be
introducing Karis so it's a really good
deep learning library makes it a whole
lot easier than what we what we had
so far so in this case what I won't try
and do is I had this function y equals x
squared nice and easy I want to try and
learn that ok so in this case I'm not
trying to split this on a test and train
that's not really the point of this talk
it's just to show you that care is this
easy enough to do I / 25 because that's
a maximum just because it's always nice
to be between 0 and 1 and by the way
this will this will be my github later
on yeah okay so what you end up doing I
hope you can see this is we create this
thing called sequential right so all
this is imported from Charis and then we
add a layer so in this case there's only
one x which is why the dimension input
dimensions one and the movie output one
right so and win the optimizer you can
call whatever you want to and then we
minimize in this ms e error right so
once we do that because i only have one
thing this is what I get okay because I
so y equals W X in this case right so I
only have one way because of that I get
one straight line so now i want to i'm
going to change that to to right so i
have two of these things to two nodes
and in that case when i do that i get i
get slightly won't eat monkey thing
right so in this case the f thing which
i ignored was a relative function okay
so it really isn't matter what that
activation is too much but the point is
you got four lines of code to write get
this neural net right i can keep adding
these layers I'll i've increased it 32
no particular reason why i chose 32 but
once i do that it's still not going
getting that much better but we're
starting to see the shape right the
whole idea of deep networks is that we
are adding more and more layers
do we have two minutes right okay so
before we clapped don't start early yeah
so I've added two layers and I get this
nice well well y equals x squared
function right so the more and more
layers that I ad group it'll turn out to
be nice nicer right now if I was to do
this intensive flow just to show you the
amount of code that i had right get the
same thing if they're not a code that i
had to write right so Karis makes it
like four or five lines of code and you
get the output and the other thing that
I really did mention is that you don't
have to do back propagation manually
right so this takes care of everything
well tensorflow does it as well but
Karis easily on top of tensile or tierno
and makes it a whole lot easier if you
go to the repository there is another
another thing called LST ms if you won't
take a look at it but in this deep
learning a notebook is just the base
just the basic things that you have so
and these are the references and
questions another question for lightning
taught us clap thank you very much
Sachin so I have been asked in between
each talk to tell some jokes coming up
let's get started the quicker we change
over the less jokes you're here I'm not
much of a comedian though so instead I'm
my joke who's going to be a little bits
of I guess my background and stuff at
home and talk about I voluntarily use
windows which I guess qualifies as a
joke but it's true my name's Steve dower
actually worked for Microsoft and I'm
the Python windows buildmaster likely
responsible for that so as each break
comes up and I have a chance I'm going
to tell you a little bit about Python on
windows because I can because they gave
me a microphone and no one's going to
tear me down from up yes so I'll use it
but right now are you ready Rob
yesterday showing my screen totally
wrong but that's okay that's right gonna
pretend this all works seamlessly
where's pretend everyone else can say it
as well oh yeah so this is my chopper
it must be an operating system probably
yeah all right Rob he is going to talk
about dig tag cloud Dada workflow
management okay take it away thank you
so I'm going to talk about dig dag it's
a new open source project from treasure
data created by sada who's in the middle
of the room so to go through my talk I'm
actually going to go through a dig dag
workflow and actually as it's going to
open up slabs as we go through so we'll
see if this is magically work so that's
terminal and so with the goal with dig
dag was to provide an intermediary
auction for easy to get started but
still powerful 24 more complex use cases
and for managing workflows either
locally or between distributed systems
in the cloud we chose to use a llamo
based configuration system so that you
can get started easily and of course the
terminal is over here so I'm going to
run big dag and so oh and of course it
pops up over here so dig dag allows you
to build repeatable data pipelines you
build it as code run in the cloud or run
it on other systems we liked code
because for all the nice reasons that
github gives you and again the wrong
screen so why would you use dig dug well
let's say you have Python and you want
to coordinate Python jobs with other
cloud system processing as data becomes
larger we're using cloud systems to
allow us to collect data scale run
processing a redshift bigquery analyze
data that's in s3 how do you manage
dependencies when it's not always on
your computer so that's what we wanted
to solve simple to get started develop
locally and then push to the cloud and
so anything you can do in the cloud for
managing this workflow you can also do
on your computer and so that way we
wanted the dev and prod switch to be a
core element of what we created and then
powerful for advanced use cases you can
create tests programmatically SLA emails
error notification parameterization and
pass to task or work too
flow to work for the dependencies run on
Python Ruby postgres treasure data spark
bigquery coming soon and so you can run
any options you want and so if I make
this a little bit smaller so what we've
been going through is a simple workflow
goes top to bottom you can also define
it as a dag but this is defined as
groups of tasks and so we've gone
through we're running a Python to allow
us to wait between tasks and so you can
pull in a method and run it as part of
your workflow and so right now actually
it's running a query in the cloud and
it's running one of the more advanced
use cases that we were described which
is data validation we see that across a
lot of our customers oh and that's how I
know if I'm running behind and so in
this case we actually run a sequel query
store the last results check to see if
those results are under a certain amount
for see if we have the amount of records
that we would have expected during a day
for example and then we can send an
email if that's not the case what you're
seeing is an example of us grouping
tasks and so this is one of the options
in addition to defining the dag
dynamically because for a lot of our
customers and users we found that they
liked to be able to organize their tasks
not only based on direct dependencies
but actually based on the part of
processing that was occurring this is
where all the preparation occurs this is
all where the analysis occurs this is us
sending it to a machine learning model
to be trained and then this is us
deploying it to run into production and
so rather than having that not be
explicit they want to explicit and
define it dynamically another option so
you can host the open source project you
can use it run it locally hosted in the
cloud manage work flows across many
systems but you can also just deploy
that workload to treasure data so this
is you know a new all is going to be a
new offering for us and so if you don't
want to manage the server the meditate
store the database for your workflow
processing you can use treasure data but
if you want to learn more this huge
screen shows the dig dial website and so
here you can learn how to create
workflows you can learn about the
different operators we currently have
available we have a growing user base
amongst our customers but also people in
the open source community so if you have
any questions about what you can do with
this or why you might want to use it
happy to talk after thank you do we have
Kim K handy s coming up so first windows
fact I'm going to throw out your Python
existed as Python for dose before it was
Python for windows which makes it about
as old as Python itself because dust was
only when did that day off before 95
she's that's old so Mike Hammond did the
bulk of the work to bring Python to
Windows still has a credit in the
Installer at the end it's and we're
still very thankful for him bringing it
to so many more users king k is has a
very clever kid by the looks of it and
it's going to be telling us about my
shake the smartphone seismic network
yeah I put this mark here you can see
that actually I think I'm still a baby
in Python community or at least a
toddler because i only have three years
experience even younger than PI data and
so today i will talk about like the
project i'm working on my shake so we
try to build a smartphone-sized mcknight
work that using everyone's the
smartphone sensors like XR meters inside
to detect the earthquakes so we
collaborated with digital accounts in
Silicon Valley Innovation Center and I'm
also Moore Foundation funded us so I'm
from actually Berkeley's that mangy cur
lab so we know that we have earthquakes
all over the world you can see each of
these thoughts is one earthquake and we
also know we have seismic stations to a
monitor the earthquakes but they are
very expensive like one side
maybe two hundred thousand dollars but
if we can build a seismic network using
smartphones so we have millions of
smartphones at almost no cost so this is
the goal of this project and also we
know the hazards of earthquakes is very
high like the show in here the womb
color here you can see a lot of places
but they actually don't have seismic
stations like Nepal just to have a
earthquake but they only have a handful
of seismic stations may be less than
five but they actually they have like
six mini smartphones in in Nepal so if
we have that smartphone seismic network
we can actually build a warning system
like two more people people before a
large shaking arrive at cosmin do so but
you may ask like we are carry our phones
every day working running and doing all
kinds of activities so if we record a
signal like this like this is smart
phone recordings how do I know whether
this is an earthquake or this is just
like I'm jump junking of floor or
something so this is one of the first
girl so we collected data so this is a
one smartphone data I just want to give
you a test can tell me where is the
earthquake this is contains a magnitude
7.8 earthquake at about 100 kilometers
away from the like oak door so you can
see all these is three component inos
and this is like the largest thing you
know here actually is like a human
activity so if we zoom in to this box
here you can see the earthquake actually
is here so what we are doing is that we
try to find the characteristic between
different motions and then build a
classifier behind that so this is
another example of earthquakes so you
can see earthquake have its own features
so I don't have time to talk about that
but we can talk later but we buta
artificial neural network up classifier
running on the phone to detect whether
this is a earthquake on non earthquakes
and then so we have millions of
smartphones so we we can take advantage
of that if we have a night work of
smartphone
during the earthquake it will not be
only one smartphone trigger or detect
the earthquake it will be like a cup of
magnesia or magenta thoughts is the
phone's detected the earthquake so this
is why we can aggregate the results
basically doing a spatial and temporal
class a clustering of these multiple
phones so this is the actually the app
we build we have the artificial neural
network a classifier running on each
phone and then detect the earthquake
then we have the clouds basically to
classify to do a clustering algorithm to
locate the earthquake and then we save
the data into the database so currently
we have more than 200,000 people
download so this map is mimic the
Earth's night map but it's actually the
my shake registered users actually light
up the world you can see we have a black
hole in China because we don't have
people in China have don't have the
access to the google play store so that
the count downloads the app so anyway in
the last of five months is we actually
release the in fabric so you can see we
recorded the earthquakes all over the
world we record the more than 200
earthquakes so the larger size is like
the magnitude is larger and the colors
showing your different tabs so this way
we actually think that we can in the
future to set up a really low-cost
smartphone seismic night work so if you
have ideas or suggestions you can talk
with me so our address is my shake top
berkeley.edu thanks thank you
how was that next Vic you coming up
excellent no slides no thanks I I'm just
going to take literally just two minutes
so I'm sohaib I'm a data scientist at
Ballard water analytics where data
analytics platform for primarily water
utilities also gas sometimes electric we
basically help we basically look at
water consumption data and we help
utilities identify anomalous events like
leaks meter tampering water theft that
sort of stuff that helps them reduce
their revenue loss and you can imagine
especially in California with the draw
it and everything and especially with
the government regulations that comes
with it you know in terms of like water
conservation etc utilities are
especially sensitive about not losing
money you know through these kind of
link events so currently we're hiring a
data science consultant for a
contracting position we have lots of
interesting problems to work on we have
lots of ideas that currently exist as
just ideas and we want to you know we
need we need people to like kind of like
just you know build that product through
so our tech stack is the usual Python
our SQL stuff so if that's something
that you you know that might interest
you you know fits within your experience
etc just come find me I'll be here for a
bit more today and also be here tomorrow
thanks Thank You mr. room is alpha
sheets if you'd like to come up and
start getting plugged in I'll throw out
the next windows fact that you it's been
available for 20 years who thinks Python
3 is more popular than Python 2 on
Windows congratulations you're right by
every metric that I have available which
includes downloads from patent dioxide
which includes people using it in visual
studio which includes crash reports
pattern 3 is actually more popular than
Python
to on Windows these days so we are
making progress we're getting to a much
better place for the language as a whole
and my next fact after this talk and we
got signal coming through I have more
time to fill in so I plugged it in you
gotta I anyone know how to fix this is a
bunch of red yeah thank you James keep
killing time i don't know i'm i'm
letting everyone be very entertained by
this because everyone with a mac and a
pc has had a working projector so the
other cool fact that you may not know
this this is fairly recent development
and it it occurred too much cheering
around the office for us have it in my
bag what do you think happens if you
type hip install numpy on window this is
a mac adapter so we just have someone
else go first who thinks that it blows
up and explodes and all sorts of
interesting ways okay who thinks it
complains about not having a compiler
okay technical difficulties let's have
young chin I think young chow if you'd
like to come up and plug in who thinks
that it just downloads a wheel and
extracts the wheel and you can have
numpy on Windows my typing pigments or
numpy correct the team look did that
everyone should buy them a drink because
that's an amazing amount of work to get
wheels together phenom pie but it had
solved one of the biggest pain points
that exists and and I mean continuum did
it first but the team that used proper
open source tools to make a wheel for
number on Windows deserve a beer
the compiler that you used sorry I CC
know the I fought yeah we got screen
mirrored quiet so while the young Joe is
getting a screen together we are going
to hear about how to write and run
biology using Python with robots I hope
do any of the upcoming lightning talks
have a windows machine we can skip to
you expose them Fatima what this one
looks like a Mac as well isn't it so
it's that's not guaranteed at this point
yeah so what is what what are you using
second one oh there we go oh you ready
Oh
okay everybody today I'm going to talk
about basically running an experiment on
the lab like a web experiment apology
get experiment on the on the web so
first thing first is I look for
transcript pic which is a cloud that so
I'm just gonna talk about a bunch of
open source stuff we have and how we
integrate that lefty Python stark so on
this is transcript basically we allow
you to write any experiment and run it
from the comfort of a web browser and as
well as basically rather than using
robotics so if you could cook at this
can see this is like a book sale we have
to run experiments but what I'm going to
focus on today's on how do you write
this code so this is all in Python so in
order to do that we open salsa standard
for writing experiments caught know the
protocol data and essentially this
standard can be used to specify any
experiment including biological
experiments chemical experiments or any
other kinds of experiments so to go
through this process going to bring up a
demo notebook and here I'm just go to
like a bunch of basics about other
protocol so i am writing experiment for
qpcr only biologists are there in this
room actually cool at least two great
okay so cool qpcr is a very common
experiment run by biologists to amplify
DNA I supposed to look at sudden weather
student genes are present in the cell so
this is like a brief brief like sketch
of a PCR experiment so here I'm creating
a dictionary up experiment so here I'm
creating playing a plate I'm
transferring some stuff from this play
to the other plate and I'm sealing it
and then running to mow Psychlo on it
and then once i do that of this object
which essentially is a representation of
this experiment and if this experiment
it's now portable and i can dump it the
json i can transmit or anybody and we
can then run it after that so here i'm
creating a QP c around object and here
my tree summoning of run oh geez cool
and once it's something to run can
actually see from this is a bit
well this works well okay it's a phone
during life maybe something to run then
you can see like the run project and
after that you can do a bunch of stuff
of this run right you can have like can
analyze the results of this run so here
we are like accessing a data object and
this object basically uses all the
common like common panda stack tues so
for example I can look at my data
subtracting datasets here which is the
pandas dataframe I can dig into this
data for example I can be like oh how
does be on the first day does that look
like so by some hero we have like
emitted I fails which you can then
figure out what this data set look like
I can download this data set as well so
you can do a bunch of other interesting
things you can look at the instructions
that consist of this data set can look
at the data that was associated this
instructions as well as you can also run
a bunch of kinematics and open source
analysis functions which we use to
basically look analyze data and look at
how the experiment went so yep I think
that's the vault camera have and thanks
for expecting me and just check out
other protocol daughter as well as our
opens ah 5recent github specialist
cryptic and hope you guys could
contribute to it as well thanks
is matt davis reddit are you going to
have another go let's have another go
and while we're getting set up again I
don't have a window respect for you this
time but since you stuck around for it
here's something that's not actually a
fact we don't have an official made up
and drink up tonight but if we did have
one it would probably be a thirsty bear
brewing company 661 Howard Street so
just up the road thirsty bear brewing
company is hypothetically where we all
may go and hang out and have a drink
after lightning talks are done so if you
happen to be there as well we can hang
out and have some fun are we good this
time looks good alright this is alpha
sheets collaborative programmable
spreadsheets yep ah-ah-ah
let's play
their displays
if someone would like to volunteer to do
a lightning talk on setting up your
laptop for lightning talks there would
be a great topic by that it's a little
late in the day for it but yes put that
down first on the list next time all
right we're here please click click keep
this configuration oh my god okay hold
on wait wait wait wait wait I'm going to
press the apply button and everything's
going to be just fine wait wait wait
reply button you need to get any change
the setting again wait hold on hold on
hold on it's wait wait wait wait wait
for this keep hold on wait keep keep
keep keep okay and that concludes the
lightning talk I'm just kidding alright
so i am alex i am the CEO and a
cofounder of alpha sheets so what alpha
sheets is is it's a programmable
web-based spreadsheet basically like
excel or google sheets so for example
you can do cell references and copy
paste them down and do arithmetic on the
references the fun stuff is that you can
also use Python or sinkhole directly in
the sheets so what happens we type range
6 here well range six shows up the
Python code directly evaluates in the
spreadsheet and the values here update
so yeah this is pretty cool all right
what's this useful for Alva sheets can
be used to help collaboration between
technical people and non-technical
people people who know how to code and
write do analyses in Python and people
who really only know how to fiddle
around with things in Excel so I'm going
to just show a quick demonstration of
such a program so small display this
regard we're Harding front in people
so this is a global code editor where
you can we include all of our imports
and global functions so I'm going to
build a thing that takes stock data from
a certain time frame and plots the
closing prices and the moving average of
those prices so here you can just put
the date-time object directly in the
cell subtract 180 days from it and now
we're going to pull the data from yahoo
finance with the ticker and holy [ __ ]
the ticker and the information the
closing and start date right here so
just with this one command we pull the
Python data frame from the web and I got
all this opening closing volume
information for Yahoo for Google from
this ticker over this timeframe now if
you want to plot this information it's
as simple as referencing the clothes
column of the state of frame and
pressing plot voila now that's how you
want to find the moving average of what
these prices look like that's pretty
easy too so let's say the moving average
you want to look at is twenty right now
you can just create a new column here
and reference the clothes column and
call for front-end developers
this should be referencing be4 here and
we have all the moving averages these
are all names because this is a 20-day
moving average and if we want to plot
what's in this moving average it's as
simple as just referencing the sky here
and plotting that too so there we have
it quick quick and dirty analysis of
stock prices and moving averages over
some time frame so what do we do with
this let's say you want to share this
with someone who doesn't know how to
code it's as simple as clicking a link
and shoot shoot me off and yeah we all
figure we are now that was the clapping
that's the clapping that's awesome that
I want to clap that again now that's
thanks that is really key that see that
all right sweet thanks that was totally
worth fighting the monitors all right up
next is this matt davis coming up you
Matt excellent always brought his family
awesome so next next windows fact I said
before that I have the download stats
from python org which is the main place
where people on Windows get there python
from there's you know there's there's
some people to continue on think that
they're the main place but it's actually
python.org reverent downloads it from
how many downloads a month do you think
windows sees windows versions of patency
let's let's let's seven we have said do
I have any advance on seven any any
advance on seven thing i 827 any any
events on that this is per month
remember not not in the last minute
there's any higher anyway can have a
thousand thousand from anyone anyone
know 10,000 there have 10,000 the back
anyone want to go higher than that
15,000 anymore 20,000 we're going let's
go a little quicker here any any advance
on 20,000 and he had bet there's a
hundred thousand one hundred thousand
per one hundred and fifteen thousand per
month can I get an advance
that anymore anymore 115 200,000 per
month let's get four million per month
anyone want to go about four million per
month any 15 million but three of those
how did you know it is actually about
four and a half million downloads a
month of Python for windows from
python.org which frankly blew my mind
and my next set of facts is going to
break that down a little bit more for
you but right now we have matt davis is
going to talk about snake vis all right
this is a really quick rundown of
profiling in python which will conclude
with snake this so when you want to make
your code go faster you have to know
which part of it is slow and why it's
slow so that's where profiling comes in
profiling as a tool built into Python
that will tell you which functions in
your code are taking how long so you
know load it a little bit of data so the
first tool all of these these things are
built into ipython is time it the time
it magic will run a thing a bunch of
times and then tell you how long it took
on average useful to know this is really
useful when you want to compare two
things that do the same thing and the
same like have the same result but you
want to know which one is faster note
that it's not always representative if I
had more data in these data frames these
results might be different so make sure
you're testing it on something
representative but this is really handy
and you can also if you put two percent
signs here you can get a whole block and
profile the whole thing but that just
tells you a number which things faster
the pier on magic actually gives you a
table a breakdown it opened up in this
little frame down here and these are all
of the functions this is how many times
they were called this is how long it
took they all went very fast so all you
see is zeros and if you actually want to
get something back called the P stats
object that you can read about in the
standard library you can use flags the
pure run to get that and then you can do
things like sort them and filter them to
like the top 10 so this is
you top 10 most frequently called
functions and you can save it using the
dash D flag you will save these stats to
a file and we'll come back to that so
that saves it in this directory to a
file called filtered up bra okay snake
this snake is is not built into Python
this is a thing I wrote so you have to
install it and then lodec snake this to
get the magic now when I do this it's
going to do the P run thing and then
open up this visualization of how long
different parts of your program took and
so when you hover over these things it
highlights it and then over on the left
you'll see the things like the function
name how long it took stuff like that
you can drill down into this and get
deeper into the stack to look for things
the way to interpret this is angular arc
is how much what fraction of time was
spent in that part of your code and then
as you and this is getting deeper into
the code so this is higher level you can
also go with the Icicle if you find this
easier to interpret and then it's got
the names on there too this table is the
same information in the table that I was
showing you in the notebook a second ago
but you can sort it here it's handy um
so that works in the notebook you can
also say you have some code in a file
that you want to profile go over to the
command line run the profile with see
profile give it the file name and then
what you want to run that will run it in
the profile and then Snape is how the
command line interface that will open up
your browser with the same thing so that
you can do an investigation and so the
actual underlying profiler here is built
into Python you can use it at any time
but investigating the actual data that
comes out of it is most easily done
through the visualization
like this or through sorting this
interactive table I find it much easier
than working directly with like the pcs
objects that i was showing a minute ago
so profile often when you're like when
you're just kind of general advice like
when you want your code to go faster
like don't guess about what slow because
whenever I do that I'm wrong actually
run it through a profiler find out
what's slow and then you can really dig
in make it fast thanks Thank You Stuart
Geiger is up next are you in the room
coming up awesome oh I I hope that's a
different operating system to strain
your battery there right no bit windows
virtual machine that running Linux so
that's ah well will blame the virtual
machine that's fine so four and a half
million downloads a month of Python for
Windows sounds ridiculously huge let me
break that down a little bit about one
and a half million of those are Python
35 to the latest version about 1.2
million of them are Python 27 12 the
latest one someone has a broken
continuous integration system because
the next highest version of python is
275 nobody should be downloading that
please stop whoever's doing it your
system is broken please fix it you're
downloading that thing like a million
times a month stop with that stroke I go
all right hi everybody I'm here to share
the results of something that actually
got started at a Syfy hack sprint day
that I did with Jimmy Whitaker who's
also in the room also Matthias Buscemi a
who we were looking at trying to
understand the the Jupiter organizations
and as you may know with github there's
a whole bunch of ways to do great
statistics about repositories for
example if you have an individual
repository inside an organization you
can get that but at the organization
level four groups of
prosit or ease it's sort of very
difficult to do that and one thing that
we started off was just trying to
actually get a map of all the
contributors who had made a commit to
any of the repos in any of the Jupiter
family of of organizations which
includes Jupiter Jupiter hub the IFI
Python and Jupiter attic and so one
thing that sort of came out of this was
a package package that's called that
I've called get org it's my first
package actually and it's now up on pip
so you can pip install it and I'm just
going to kind of walk you through one of
the things that you can you can do with
that so make sure this is the right I
had one that was to try and do it live
but live demos breaks so that's why I'm
just going to walk you through a
notebook that's also up on the github
repository so you can pip install it and
uses IP I leaflet as well to display a
lot of the things with maps so you do
that you enable I pi leaflet you
imported it's wrapped on top of the pie
github a package so you import get org
from github you import a github object
gh login is something file that i have
containing my API key that does not
synchronize to github then you start off
by you can have a list or just a string
of one or more mini github organizations
there's a function that is get org map
map orgs you pass in a github the github
object that you instantiate it earlier
the list of organizations and you can
have a debug level as well for how much
you want to have in that it goes through
and it returns a highly flip map that
has even display inline a dictionary of
the locations and a dictionary of the
metadata and you can see it takes a long
time if your organization has a lot of
members and a lot of repositories
especially because there's a geolocation
API we're using based on geo pie that
uses OpenStreetMap data and that's
limits us to about one query per second
so this took about 25 minutes to get all
that and so you can go through it goes
through all of these repositories and
then I you can do metadata for that and
this is actually this is a screenshot of
the image you would get normally in
leafy night by leaflets you'll be able
to zoom in and out and do a whole bunch
of cool stuff with that we there's also
functions you can write these stuff out
to different files CSV if you're doing
that I don't yet have geo JSON one thing
that we use though is to output to a
single j/s JavaScript variable that was
used for another sort of thing we wanted
more clustered map something that looks
like this so what we were able to do is
have this have it output to a single
JavaScript variable and then another
HTML and JavaScript thing using a
different visualization and plotting
library that takes in all those
coordinates and does it and the results
are sort of up here on a github bio page
and you can zoom in and you can get a
sort of a nice clustered thing and you
can see different maps of anyone who
sort of made a commit to any of the
Jupiter ipython family of repositories
and it's can be used for any anything on
this now any organization in github now
some of the caveats about this as well
are that it only it basically requires
people to herself report their own
locations in github profile we found
about half of the people who committed
to the Jupiter family do provide Python
family did not actually specify that so
we're missing about half of the people
already and as well this only gets their
most current location there's no
historical data to github stores so
you're only getting the most recent
thing about what they've contributed to
but still it's a really fun way to get a
whole bunch of maps and to sort of see
it a broad level the people who are
contributing to your organization
there's also a lot of there's a module
run issues they don't think have time to
go into right now but trying to figure
out the kinds of there's things like you
can okay what one minute so things where
you can find right now give me all the
organization the issues that are open in
any of the repose of my organization you
know more than X number of days that
have more the next number of comments
that do or do not have an assignee a lot
of things you can filter with that so as
a project yeah that's it please if
there's any features that you're
interested in anything that you're
interested in doing analytics or things
about community health about
organizations on github please open up
an issue send me an email I'm sort of
this is before my first project that
I've been working on but I'm really
excited about it so thank you very much
great thank you Greg are you here we're
going to bump you up the lists a little
bit you want to come up and get ready
while he's doing that how many people
here have ever used a pre-release
version of Python James James is prolly
created some certainly broken some belly
sorry oh I don't want to ask that how
many people are still on Python 2 and
stuck the OH okay that's not as bad as I
thought I'm sorry but so everyone else
is on Python 3 how many people are on
both who gets to use both that's that's
pretty cool that's pretty good dude who
gets to choose that they use both you
get to pick like I'll do Python 3 for
this project pythons with that project
no is it more of keds it's more of a
this employer says three this employer
says to ya this ok thank you go but the
reason that I bring up the pre-release
one is Python 36 is being developed
right now it's about to have alpha three
years out alpha 4 is about to be cut
tomorrow or the next day it just alpha 4
did not just come out today beer wait
how's this work exactly have that there
was an email that it's coming out but
it's it has not come out yet how do you
set it to mirror or do I have to just
look at this well ok so I'm not going to
try to interact with the thing but you
can see I have okay so all right I'm
going to give a short completely off the
cuff presentation about o camel which is
a statically typed language sort of
similar to standard ml and let's see I
guess the more common languages that you
might have encountered that are similar
to it are go and Scala both of those
have type inference but in go and Scala
type inference is kind of purely local
you still have to supply annotations on
your funk
and it will infer the types of local
variables whereas o camel has full in
Lee Milner style inference so whenever
you use a value anywhere it can infer
sort of a most specific type for all the
terms in the programming language the
reason why this is useful and you should
care about it is so when you're working
with Python most of the time you're not
like if there's going to be really
minimal enforcement of the contracts
that the that the functions are supposed
to provide so if you cut if you kind of
take a step back the way that you
determine whether you're using a
function correctly or not in Python is
kind of like does it throw an exception
at runtime you don't get very many
guarantees sort of are at compile time
about what your program is capable of
doing certain or certain things like
even indentation errors and in certain
circumstances can be caught at runtime
and you won't see them until you
actually exercise that good path so o
camel one of the nice things that it has
going for it is even though it has even
though it has a type system that
basically eliminates the possibility of
runtime type errors it also makes some
concessions to make everyday programming
a little bit easier for instance you get
a magical polymorphic comparison
function that you can use to compare to
arbitrary values without having to
specifically go in and define like in a
module a function specifically for
comparing them in fact that's the
example that we have up here so the
displays aren't actually mirrored so I'm
going to have to look at this thing to
sort of determine what I'm actually
telling you but so for instance this is
an example of an orderable type we are
so basically this module the
relationship between this module and the
type t unlike in an object-oriented
language is purely by convention sort of
if you use the alternate standard
library core
most of the functions built into the
language are most of the types built
into the language have a corresponding
module that will contain T and will
contain functions that are related to
that type and collectively satisfy some
laws so you can apply like a functor or
something and get back some different
type that's also useful so for instance
here you can see if something's
orderable we you know we need a type to
compare and we'd like to be able to take
two items and compare them and get an
integer back so the integer being zero
if the items are equal positive if if
the left one is greater and negative if
the right one is greater so for instance
here we're basically just passing
through to the built-in comparison
function the standard library in NF
camel is called pervasive and so if you
set so you can explicitly refer to that
module even though all of the values and
types and other stuff contain to that
module are already dumped into the
global main space thank you so here you
can sort of see down here we're
constructing a set by by sort of taking
our okay so here we're actually we're
not constructing an instance of a set
we're defining what it is to be a set a
set is is a functor which is sort of
which is kind of like a compile-time
function it takes a module which is a
collection of values and types in the
language and applies some kind of
transformation to it so so what we're
doing here is we're taking a set which
takes some module which is orderable and
it produces here the implementation is
really simple we don't check for
duplicates you don't have a way to get
the size of the set but you do have a
way to test for membership which is sort
of our type T kind of the center of the
universe from from the perspective of
the set module is the set itself and the
way that you determine membership is you
just take each element and you check
whether it's equal to the thing that you
passed in and
I actually made a mistake here using the
built-in thing we're not leverage
compare at all oh thank you Greg Severn
thank Greg all right okay Traci is up
next you I don't see anyone jumping up
claiming to be Tracy here she comes John
I need you to jump you have to jump so
this is not a windows fact this is
simply because I seem to be the only
Python core developer in the room at the
moment half of 44 Python 36 is coming
out shortly up to the weekend we need
people to test it it's so you don't have
to spend a lot of time using it you have
to switch to it permanently but if
you've got some sort of app at least get
hold of 36 run your app through it when
it breaks please come and let us know
that's drop an email to python list go
to Boggs da pata na dog report something
but it's really important for us as a
developers of Python itself that as we
make changes between versions we get
feedback on what has changed what is
broken so we can fix it before you end
up getting a dot 0 version that doesn't
work so our next talk is Tracy chillin
on focus board member and she's going to
be telling us about a journal for open
source science software it's just
science from the board yeah they're
pretty much the same so so first I want
to express my previous love of windows
NT 4.0 my last significant experience
with windows so and so thanks for the
lightning talks I appreciate getting to
speak here and someone did ask me to
talk and so a view in the room who did
not give lightning talks who would have
given a lightning talk if someone asked
you to next time put your name on the
board all right I know that we should
ask more people to speak but don't be
afraid to put your name on the board
lightning talks in particular are a
really fantastic away to talk about
something and if you bomb miserably it's
only five minutes
awesome okay so we'll see how I do all
right so I just wanted to take a few
minutes to talk about the journal for
open source software so this was a
project started by our fun Smith at
github and I Kurt the gram of our open
sigh and some other co-conspirators and
so this is the website and the goal of
the journal of open source software is
to be a developer friendly journal so
what is what does this mean so one is
that the sort of idea don't we have
enough journals are ready so the
challenge in academic systems is that
what we value our publications and
grants and software is not a publication
but it's often difficult to get software
into a sort of a standard journal
there's a lot of extra work that's
actually maybe not necessarily relevant
to the software itself so this is for
people to be able to publish their
software in in a very lightweight way so
not requiring a lot of work but the
other goal of this journal which I love
is that it's a way of enforcing but not
in a negative way but promoting good
habits around open source software so
it's the ideas to improve the quality of
software submitted and so what does that
mean I'm so if you are an author of a
software package it should take you less
than an hour to prepare and submit your
paper to Joss that means however that
you have adhered to the requirements
that Joss has so Joss paper should
contain the following authors summary
key references and then um it should be
open source for by the OSI definition
imma should have research application
and it should also have and it should
also have things like tests and code
documentation um so what you do is you
submit your journal through a github
issue
and then a reviewer looks at these
author guidelines so let's take a look
at one of these submissions I'm so these
are all submissions to the Joss journal
submitted as github issues so let's take
a look at one of them this one because
it has giant triangle confuso grams in
the title so this person and it's a you
know pi gtc south of Pi in it um so what
the github issue looks like is they
submit this thing and then the reviewers
reviewers assign themselves to papers
there's a anyone sort of with some
knowledge in the field can be a reviewer
and so reviewers say that they want to
review a paper and then they go through
the paper and there's these checkboxes
so is there a conflict of interest does
it have a repository does it have a
license does the version match the
github release does it install and does
it do what it says it's supposed to do
are there any performance gains are they
there then documentation um so there's
all these check boxes so you can see
those reviewers already gone through and
then the reviewers started to have some
questions so then there's a conversation
with the author that helps them get to
the point where all those checkboxes are
off so what I love about this is that it
improves the quality of software and
it's a it's a process that's
collaborative that makes the software
better so it's not a system of rejecting
because you don't make criteria but the
reviewer is active in the process of
helping to improve the submission and
prove the software so I was super happy
to be invited to be a part of this
journal I'm excited about where this is
going to go so if you are developing
software submitted here it's super fun
Thank You Tracy we know yes huh knock on
later we don't have does it compile on
windows as a checkbox though is that Oh
improv it's a sonic can I file an issue
on that I'll go file an issue on that in
the spirit of participation in lightning
talks I was disappointed that only half
of you will participate in fast of the
other half of people if you were asked
to emcee the lightning talks would you
do it who would get up and is it just me
it's just me that's I'm looking for
someone funnier than me to get up and do
it next time which should be everyone in
the room frankly keep you connected in
give me a second don't rush me so this
is our final lightning talk as I
mentioned earlier the way may or may not
all accidentally end up at the thirsty
bear later on and if you do happen to be
there we may happen to be there as well
and we can all hang out and have some
fun but now for our final lightning talk
I present to you a masterclass in self
rationalization James Powell is going to
speak on what is non focus so we've all
heard that this is the 20th PI data
event globally the very first party
event occurring here in Silicon Valley
in 2012 as a pi day to day on the Google
campus I've been lucky enough to be a
part of many of these events I'll give
you a couple of numbers this is the 16th
PI data event that I've spoken at today
I finished presenting the 22nd PI data
talk that I've given and this is the
temp lightning talk so I've given about
32 talks other talks or lightning talks
or tutorials at pi day events I clearly
have no better way to spend my time than
to be here with all of you but honestly
I really do I really do feel that way I
wanted to tell you briefly about numb
focus because even though we've had so
many PI data events people still ask
about none focus yesterday I gave a long
90-minute talk about numb focus and how
you can get involved and about the
projects I went to a lot of that depth
so I want to keep this very concise and
tell you two stories about numb focus
that are relevant to you and then
go get drunk story number one I hope to
see all of you here tomorrow in the
morning bright and early to see
tomorrow's keynote megan pryce the
director from HR dag the human rights
data analysis group will be here
speaking to us I want to tell you how
she came about being a speaker at PI
data I saw her speak in an event earlier
this year and in her talk she was saying
you know we've done we've done reports
commissioned by the UN about casualty
rates in conflict areas where nobody
really knew how many people were dying
there and we use statistical tools in
tistic methods to be able to inform
human rights groups that you know there
are a certain number of casualties in
this area we really need to put a lot of
focus on this this is the scope or scale
of the conflict or the refugee problem
emerging from this particular conflict
and she had one throwaway line in her
talk she said we use numpy and type I
for this and I wanted to thank the folks
behind that so after she got off stage I
walked up to her and said do you know
who's behind the tools that you
mentioned that you are using their
critical to your research and she said
well actually I don't and I said would
you be surprised to hear that it's an
organization a single nonprofit numb
focused that's behind numpy pandas
Jupiter that fiscally sponsors all of
these projects that puts a lot of effort
into ensuring the governance the
sustainability of these projects that
this very year is going to host for the
first time ever a summit of summits
where all of the project leaders will
get together and work on issues that
work across all of these projects now I
clearly didn't say it as such a long
run-on sentence but I try to convey the
meaning and she and she said oh that's
very interesting I said would you like
to come and speak it up high data event
and she agreed to speak at a PI data
event the second the second small story
I want to give you is I've gone to a lot
of pilots I've spoken at many many
events I've helped organize events like
this I've helped with other num focus
issues but and steve has as well I think
this is the second time he's MC talks is
the third or fourth of entities spoken
at but I want to tell you that when you
look at Steve or you look at me and you
say well that's a lot of effort and
that's a lot of time one thing is this
event is run by volunteers I'm a
volunteer steve is a volunteer we don't
work
focus we volunteer for numb focus we
volunteer for pi data and the effort
that we put into this is the effort that
we find we're able to put into this num
focus and PI data are always looking for
volunteers people to help out with
things as simple as introducing us the
speakers things as simple as introducing
us to companies who might be interested
in sponsoring the event or hosting the
event things like introducing us to
companies that are using the tools that
want to get in contact with the people
who are writing these tools and hand
start a dialogue oh I'm using Jupiter
inside my company for some interesting
stuff I get to run over time by the way
who are using these tools internally and
I want to contact the project developers
and ask them questions about how I can
incorporate this into you know my
commercial work those are small things
we can do i want to encourage all of you
to think about do you want to be a part
of pi data not just in the audience but
part of the creation of pi data that the
organization of pi data and if that's
something interested in I'd really like
for you to come to the booth tomorrow
speak with me or Leah we're working very
hard to build a PI data community here
in San Francisco to set the groundwork
for another event like this next year
and we need volunteers who have any
level of time commitment so if you come
to us and say you know I can put in 15
minutes a week or maybe one hour a month
or you know I'm in between jobs right
now I have a lot of time but I only have
that time for maybe a month or two
before i start my next role but i have a
lot of time right now please let us know
will tell you about things we can do and
i'll give you an example of that a
couple weeks back there was syfy and
there was an event scheduled to the same
time aside pie that Dada Dada Dada Dada
signed something it was here in San
Francisco it was the first part of the
week and last part I needed to be at
sify because I was giving a talk at sify
and it's a big event for an unfocused
that dot 0 dot assigned summit is also a
big event for an unfocused because data
has been a sponsor for num focus and for
many PI data events had passed so we
wanted to have a booth at both of the
events I flew out to San Francisco to
help run a booth at the data sign summer
but I can only be there for one day I
had to fly out the very next day to go
to scifi to get my talk there are people
in this room right here who are at this
event I think in a large part because
we put out a call for volunteers who's
willing to come to this event will give
you a free ticket help us run the booth
tell people about numb focus tell people
about PI data have conversations with
people about the open source tools tell
people why open source is important and
we have a gentleman sitting right here
who helped us run that booth for two
days and I think part of the reason that
he's here is because he said you know I
have part of an afternoon free I have a
couple couple of two days free I can get
away from work spend a couple hours here
at the event talking to people about
numb focus PI data and open source and
that's exactly the kind of volunteering
me so instead of giving me a round of
applause for kind of going over my time
beginning my talk I'd like you to give a
round of applause to all of our
volunteers who helped make this event
possible thank you so much
thank you James and that's how one more
round of applause for all of our
speakers for the lightning talks
hopefully we'll get more of you up at
the next set of lightning talks we do
next payday 2 conference have a good
night or see you at the thirsty bear see
you tomorrow